The scenes we just showed you were in 2008 in the United States
A severe financial crisis is the second worst economic crisis in the history
America after the great depression in the thirties
It then moved from the US to other countries causing
an unprecedented global economic and financial chaos all over the world
The chief reason for that crisis was the greedy financial institutions and major banks
that facilitated over-borrowing without control
Nevertheless, a mysterious and interesting player was going to appear at that time
and would change this whole global financial system later in the future
What player? What Changes?
I'm Ashraf Ibrahim, and this is the ‘Crypto Economic Informant’
a new series of short focused episodes to be guide keys to the world of digital currencies
the huge opportunities it offers to investors, individuals, entities and companies
in addition to its inherent dangers, and how they are likely going to change the entire global financial system in the future
I would like to highlight an issue of significance, not all Arab countries allow
digital currencies exchanging so far, for example,
most of the Gulf countries allow it, while other countries such as Iraq, Egypt and Algeria do not allow it anyway
So please, pay attention to this matter of necessity
let's get to it
On August 18 2008, the same year of the crisis, during this theatrical chaos
a domain or website appeared quietly on the Internet with the address Bitcoin.org
It was registered by an unknown person with an identity protected through the WhoisGuard service
No one knows who he/she is, nor what this site is exactly for
This was the case all along the first 72 days, then on October 31
a crypto mailing list appeared on metzdowd.com announced by a person or group of people, no one knows,
under the pseudonym "Satoshi Nakamoto", they acclaimed that they had worked on a new fully functional electronic Peer-to-Peer monetary system
Through this system, a currency called Bitcoin will be
traded / exchanged among individuals directly and privately,
third parties are excluded as well as other central monitoring authority,
and with the announcement, a file containing all the details was published called the “White Paper”,
which later became the Bitcoin Constitution
This was the first appearance of the mysterious character of Satoshi Nakamoto on the Internet,
and the first time the world knew about that new monetary system, as well as the entire process of currency production,
exchanging and dealing, through the "white paper", a 12-year-old written guide
that revolutionized the global financial system, a revolution that is still going on and its effect is increasing non-stop
The posts that were published under the name “Satoshi Nakamoto” in 2008 and 2009,
explicitly stated that the reason for creating this digital monetary system
was mainly to remove external intermediaries who had to be present to make money transfers
Intermediaries, such as banks, credit card companies and others,
are the system lords who make huge profits annually from transaction fees,
unlike transactions in Bitcoin, which will be zero fees.
If we take a look at the net revenues of Visa company last year for example, in 2021,
revenues exceeded 24 billion dollars, an increase of 10% more than 2020
Last August, the net revenues of the banking and investment services
giant JPMorgan exceeded 121 billion dollars in 12 months
Another reason for bitcoin's innovation was the problems caused by traditional currencies
exchanging that are being controlled by central banks that are controlling the wealth of nations in favor of a limited class as a result
Consequently, chaos or crises that occur in the monetary system due to financial institutions
mis-conduct is borne almost entirely by consumers and taxpayers, as happened in 2008
Central banks can also waste individuals’ savings if they decide to print money
in order to pay off their local debts for example. This in the long term leads to an increase in money circulation,
thus the inflation rate rises, consequently, squandering the value of individuals’ savings
by reducing their purchasing power. The inevitable end of this series is the deterioration of their living standards as a result
On the contrary, in the Bitcoin monetary system, as a possible future alternative to traditional currencies,
such problems and risks do not exist as there is neither third party in the transactions nor a central authority that
possesses tools through which individuals may be impoverished if those intermediaries mis-conduct
This was a quick talk about the emergence of Bitcoin, as the first and most famous cryptocurrency in the world
The next episode, God willing, will be a simplified explanation of “Blockchain”,
what it is and how it is working as a basis for the cryptocurrency system.
This episode is sponsored by the "rain" app,
which is the first platform licensed by the Central Bank of Bahrain for digital currencies exchanging
Last but not least don’t forget to subscribe to the channel,
activate the bell to cope up with the new crucial series
See you, bye